starting off this hour is gonna be
Kristen in Greensboro North Carolina hey
Kristen welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave it's an honor to speak to you
you too merry Christmas to you thank you
how can I help I'm calling today because
my husband and I are recent graduates of
SPU and we are now in that precarious
position of trying to pay off his
student loans he just earned his
doctorate and the result of that is
about 150 K in student loan debt so
what's his doctorate in communication
studies it's in what communication
communication studies okay what's he
gonna do teach yeah he already is
teaching actually okay what's he making
42
I'm sorry professors don't make 42 with
PhDs it's a contract position so it's
he's just starting out I'm only like a
hundred and forty two is what I want to
be making so when's he getting that job
he's already started no the one hundred
and forty two thousand dollars are oh
you don't go spend a hundred eighty
grand to work for 42 right yeah so I
mean with my salary added on to that
we're at about 72 okay I really got to
stay on this career thing because I'm
really disturbed you you are telling me
that he is going to be making north of a
hundred as a professor I hope some day
yes no darlin that's that's starting out
I mean really I mean a communica PhD in
communications teaching communications
in a in a institution of higher learning
would pay north of a hundred thousand
dollars that's the going rate I mean
that's the one rate why why in the world
would you do anything else after going
to all this trouble and spending all
this money
why what's your hesitation I don't
understand
he tried I mean we we've tried to find
positions that we're a better paying
than this and and this was really the
only thing we were a little line up I
guess um he he was on the market for
quite a while and there's just a lot of
people applying for the same positions
in his field okay well we've got to work
on this because you guys are spent so
much money on this that you you don't
have a choice he's got to go make more
money than this yeah and so he's you
know his job hunt is ongoing until he
learns something north of a hundred I
mean it's not there this isn't you know
you have to believe that I mean and you
have to go get that and do that that's
just not you know it's absolutely crazy
to say I spend a hundred 80 grand to
make 40 - yeah thank you just with I
mean obviously interest will continue to
build so there's that concern as well
yeah but the concern is is that making
70 grand you guys have two hundred
thousand dollars in debt and you
shouldn't be making 70 grand you ought
to be making 170 grand yeah yeah that's
the concern and that solves a lot of
your problem I mean because right now
you are facing a huge mountain with a
tiny shovel yeah and you know what we
need is what we need is a big shovel to
attack a big mountain yeah and that's
why I went there is just for you I'm not
trying to shame you or something but I
mean you guys have really got to get
your you need to get some professional
career counseling and coaching and and
find out how in the world you'll and
professorships and what the process is
because just throwing your name out and
applications and saying oh there's a lot
of people in the field so I can't win I
that's not okay you guys gotta go make
some money and he has the ability it's
got a frickin PhD and that solves
everything you got then in the meantime
you're gonna tread water because you're
not gonna make big progress with the
ratios you're giving me a shovel to hole
a $200,000 hole with a $70,000 shovel
and the good news is is that he should
be
making a whole lot more and so that is
the answer to you guys dilemma is let's
get him employed as he should be and
spent all of our time on that so you can
do this you can do it I wish I could
help you out you know maybe I haven't
called Ken Coleman show Ken may have
some insight on how to land a PhD into a
professorship I don't I've never done
that but but I work with enough PhDs in
professorships that I know that you know
that is a typical income